davon ist ja okay leute könnte es jetzt
schaffen es könnte man erste energien
ein
dabei gleichzeitig von vorne
jo leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einem brötchen ende games und um die
ganze reihe anfang mal weg zu lassen
haben uns gedacht hatte wir starten
einfach mal direkt aus der runde
in den tiefen des rund es wisst ja und
ja ja ja ich hab jetzt mal die
erschwerten gelten ein richtiger
englisch ja und dieser schnauferl in der
im teams teams gar nicht das ist dennis
weiten bogen einfach ja
robert wenn es wenn es in archer ist
dann bin ich im arsch wenn ich im kopf
trifft ich bin immer schon in ihrem kopf
trifft ha jo ja okay dann lederhosen
schwert ohne rüstung gegen ihn
anzutreten effekt nicht so schlau der
richtung ist gegner der richtung des
gegner habe ich hatte hier habe ich
abgeschlossen ich habe einen hab ich
mich regen war das nicht ein
ich habe gegeben als geile scheiße läuft
bei die ada yonath mal getroffen und
alte das war gerade recht eigentlich
richtig selbstmordkommandos wir einfach
unglück ohne rüstung einen angegriffen
mit allerdings ihr wisst schon mit dir
und so die adia schwert erschwert habe
ich auch nicht ohne rüstung und er hat
sogar du bist ein mensch angesteckt
nicht töten nicht töten bitte nicht haha
nein nein aber ist denn die leute auf
mich zu
die leute die jetzt denken nicht so
direkt abschlecken schlecht und ich habe
acht aber auch mehr immer immer diese
range bogen kämpfer alter so ärgerlich
denn anzunähern bisschen besser direkt
noch 8
ich glaube ich mache die woche das video
das video
die leute die kein plan haben worüber
wir reden hinschaut einfach psk
challenge ich habe jetzt den brustpanzer
diashow alle lebensalter nicht einfach
achten ich habe einfach achteinhalb
rüstungs punkte und ich hab mein schwert
manchmal verzaubert ich wäre jetzt schon
alles kaputt ich meine ich mach jetzt
alles schon liebe ich konnte sich noch
weiter nur ein bisschen offenbar move
und jetzt das das war jetzt echt tricky
junge das war jetzt echt ricky kam ein
zweites dir sprechen gott sei dank alt
wie tricky man erst verschwindet dieses
wegen der entspannten table so dass ich
das teil nicht mehr im inventar und dann
werde ich weg report das heißt ich habe
das teil nicht verloren
unterricht aber ich habe glück gehabt
und scharfes 1 auf dem schwert perfekt
man das ist echt geil ist geil
equipments wenn jetzt nicht verpacken
kann ich relativ wenig passieren
löffler alter mein kollege hat mir
gerade hier nach super bowl
ich habe heute auf facebook alle
menschen irritiert mit zum richtig
geilen post hab einfach geschrieben
nachher super bowl go lakers ehrlich
sind ja nicht leute darauf reingefallen
oder ich weiß manche schon bestimmt
richtig dumme in der perle vertauscht
die krankheit alter der karte zuschauen
ich höre betroffen endlich im kaktus der
wahl getroffen wäre die wogen skills
bogens gleichmachen unseres geführt ich
habe einfach
es passt nicht so wirklich zu meinem
schwager dass ich hier so ein teil auf
habt wisst ihr sohn jeden tricks kann
sich treffen im die asbest alter wie ich
ab gehälter junge boston gestik aus
eskaliere ich halte ich habe ja alles
kaputt zwei verbleibenden spiele es gibt
nur noch ein festival mit ihm im
deathmatch habe ich es überhaupt habe
ich dir hatten wir die es hier gibt es
dort keine rüstung an läutet keine dead
keine rossiter
ich habe glaub ich noch nie ändern vor
allem noch nie auf aufnahme könnt ihr
könnt jetzt erste mal sein also meinst
du drauf hast
der cup den look von die eingesammelt
jetzt hat der rüstung
wenn er bis jetzt keine rüstung halter
ist wahrscheinlich ziemlich schlecht der
tempel alter werte ohne brüstung bis
überleben ich hab' ich hab noch nicht
voll regenerierte aber gut wie schaffst
durch ach ja leute übrigens ich hab s
schinken kittner hier ich schon drauf
wenn ich jetzt hier rechtsklick mache
ich muss nicht mal irgendwie schauen
dann ist mein hunger leiste sofort
denken okay leute wirklich könnte es
jetzt schaffen das könnte man erste
energie musik sein und vielleicht seid
ihr dabei vielleicht hat er dabei die
grafik von vorne an
8.12 rentenalter ja
ein bisschen dumm dass er sich jetzt mal
selbst mit der enter perle gekillt hat
bisschen dumm von ihm aber das wort hat
es mein erster sieg auf aufnahme und ja
ich freue mich dass ihr dabei gewesen
seid richtig geil
ja leute mit dabei jedem tag waren the
local marius er ist wieder in der
beschreibung
falls ihr noch nicht angeschaut hat
schaut manchmal an der macht echt gute
videos und dazu ist noch nicht kennt
jeder
dazu hat zu halten viel dazu beigetragen
aber ich brauche ihn trotzdem einen die
beschreibung weil ich alle so lieb hat
und ja an alle meine abonnenten und alle
leute jetzt hier sehen ganz liebe grüße
hat einen schönen tag und in diesem
sinne service macht